bonsoir le cette suite en direct de 18 à
19 heures du lundi au jeudi une heure
pour faire le point sur l'actualité
locale avec nos reportages et nos
invités déjà sur ce plateau j'accueille
ce soir ni bordeaux bonsoir vous êtes la
présidente du comité ile de france de l'
association des cardiaques congénitaux
également membre du conseil
d'administration d'aliance du coeur
jusqu'au 4 novembre se tient la semaine
nationale de prévention des maladies
cardiovasculaires avec cette opération
donne au coeur pour éduquer et pour
récolter des fonds également on parlera
de l'aspect éducation tout à l'heure
avec vous est déjà un mot par rapport
aux dons ils sont nécessaires pour vos
associations pour quoi ils servent à
quoi ces dons ils sont nécessaires déjà
d'une part pour faire connaître notre
notre association fait notre fédération
déjà et aussi pour essayer de mener des
grandes campagnes disons publicitaire
enfin quand on dit publicitaire pour
faire connaître effectivement tout ce
qui peut toucher le coeur et essayer de
combattre dix ans ce fléau qui touche
beaucoup beaucoup de personnes donc les
dons nous servent à faire de grandes
campagnes à faire dans les villes des
démonstrations comment comment sauver
eux des personnes qui sont fiers de la
prévention de la prévention voilà
pourquoi nous demandons disons
aux personnes de bien vouloir nous faire
des dons qui seront bien sûr bien
utilisé pour pour sauver des pour sauver
des vies et pour aider aussi les
familles qui se retrouvent dans des
situations des fois très dramatique
l'opération donne au coeur c'est
jusqu'au 4 novembre on va en parler plus
en détail avec vous parler également de
cette semaine nationale de prévention
sur ce plateau est tellement ce soir
jeunes à s'ouvrir on forge anna lapaj
culture la chronique culture dans un
quart d'heure comme tous les mercredis
oui avec l'académie équestre de bartabas
académie du spectacle équestre de
bartabas nous vous racontons tout sur le
spectacle la voie de l'écuyer la
chronique culture chaque mercredi en
direct aux alentours de 18h15 la suite
du sommaire de ce 31 octobre en images à
présent les principaux titres montigny
le bretonneux cité de l'espace ce n'est
peut-être pas une illusion elle le cnes
l'agencé spatiale française vient
d'organiser un congrès international
l'estac à une école spécialisée dans la
conception d'engins spatiaux va
s'implanter dans la commune débat agité
au conseil régional d'île de france
autour du sdrif et le schéma directeur
de la région ile de france ps et ump
s'opposent retour sur les derniers
débats ce mercredi 31 octobre c'est
halloween et contrairement aux années
précédentes la fête américaine connaît
un regain de popularité en témoigne ce
magasin de farces et attrapes à montigny
le bretonneux pris d'assaut âmes
sensibles s'abstenir et puis à direction
l'académie du spectacle équestre de
versailles à la découverte du nouveau
spectacle chorégraphié par bartabas la
voie de l'écuyer johanna vous en parlait
il ya quelques instants ce sera à
retrouver lors de la page culture le
schéma régional d'aménagement en
ile-de-france discuté actuellement et
l'ambiance est pour le moins tendues
entre le ps et l'ump le point sur les
dernières avancées un sujet signé de
notre confrère de votv c'est otv florent
philippe
affrontement gauche droite au conseil
régional d'ile-de-france sur le sdrif le
document qui dessinent le visage de la
région d'ici à 2030 pour l'ump ce drif
n'est pas acceptable il repose sur le
projet du métro automatique du grand
paris un dossier pour lequel l'état n'a
pas mis le milliards manquants sur la
table moi je dis attention danger ce
schéma directeur qui permet aux maires
urbanisées et de créer l'emploi partout
en ile de france c'est des
embouteillages crr saturé c'est des
lignes de train qui ne tiendront pas le
charge pour l'ump la non inscription du
milliard d'euros par l'état pour le
grand paris pose la question de la
légitimité de ce nouveau sdrif une
motion de rejet était déposée par
valérie pécresse du côté de la majorité
de gauche on maintient le cap il est
nécessaire de renouveler le sdrif dès
maintenant l'enjeu c'est de sortir d'un
schéma directeur qui datent de 94 vous
imaginez un petit peu l'obsolescence des
documents et c'est de faire en sorte de
répondre à des défis qui sont là défi
très très concrets comme on se loge
comment on se nourrit comme on on
travaille le sdrif a suscité le dépôt de
plus de 300 amendements la gauche
disposant de la majorité le sdrif
devrait être votée sans difficulté
toutefois son adoption et son
approbation ne devrait pas intervenir
avant la fin de l'année 2013 à l'issue
d'une enquête publique qui doit débuter
en mars 2013
cette information concernant le grand
paris à présent après l'inquiétude des
élus suite à l'absence de plus d'un
milliard d'euros dans le projet de
budget 2013 2015 pour permettre le
financement du super métro qui doit
relier entre elles la banlieue
parisienne jean marc ayrault le premier
ministre a annoncé qu'une dotation
suffisante serait bien versée si besoin
aux maîtres d'ouvragé la société du
grand paris une nuance qui souligne
qu'un audit est en cours pour déterminer
l'aspect prioritaire ou non du dossier
europe ecologie les verts se satisfait
de ce retour sur un projet est lancé par
nicolas sarkozy la droite il voit tout
simplement un abandon pur et simple de
ces 200 km de métro et 72 nouvelle gare
la semaine nationale de prévention des
maladies cardiovasculaires c'est en ce
moment et on va en parler avec notre
invité tout de suite
notre invité annie bordeaux de
l'association nationale des cardiaques
congénitaux sur ce plateau on va déjà
donné peut-être quelques chiffres 1 400
décès par jour soit 147 milles morts par
an en france liés à ces maladies
cardiovasculaires c'est un fléau qui est
sous-estimée tout à fait il faut savoir
que les femmes sont les premières
victimes de ce fléau et et autant
pratiquement que le cancer effectivement
bron c'est disons que ça fait moins peur
mais malheureusement c'est quelque chose
qui est qui est réel je continue avec
ces chiffres qui permettent de bien
comprendre l'ampleur de la situation
selon la fédération française de
cardiologie +2 67% des français ignorent
ce nombre de décès qu'on évoquait et
sous-estiment surtout les douleurs et
les répercussions suite à un accident
cardio vasculaire parce que ce n'est pas
un os dans un accident cardio-vasculaire
on a l'impression que après une fois que
l'accident est survenu que ça se soit ça
se guérit mais il ya forcément une
conséquence derrière malheureusement en
famille à plusieurs différences et sur
des maladies cardiovasculaires bon tout
d'abord il ya l'hypertension bon petit
peu disons 10 on sait soigner il faut
savoir que dès l'instant où on a un
problème cardiaque que ça veut dire que
les que les vaisseaux ont reçu enfin une
partie de grèce pour essayer de
simplifier un petit peu et que et
forcément il y aura des séquelles qui
seront certainement des fois
irremediable dont l'importance de
prévenir et un plan coeur c'est ce pour
quoi vous militez auprès des pouvoirs
publics ce plan coeur consisterait en
quoi le plan coeur effectivement c'est
un petit peu comme le plan cancer qui a
été mis en place et déjà avoir des fonds
pour pour aller auprès de la population
pour bien leur expliquer qu'elle soit
quels sont les dangers de lors d'une
mauvaise alimentation
de dunes sédentarité du
tabac de l'obésité
viens effectivement après le diabète le
cholestérol tout ça c'est une grande
bataille qui est menée donc
parallèlement avec l'alliance du coeur
et la fédération française de
cardiologie avec lesquels on nous
travaillons dix ans pour mener à bien
cette tâche qui a commencé à peu près un
an avec notre regretté président
monsieur bull maire jean claude boulle
merde excusez moi qui lui était greffée
depuis dix ans et qui malheureusement
nous a quittés et c'est lui qui a été à
l'innovation de ceux de ses projets
c'est lui qui a justement lancé ce plan
coeur vous nous l'avez dit il ya un peu
plus d'un an aujourd'hui où en sont les
travaux justement est-ce que ce plan
coeur va voir le jour véritablement je
pense parce qu'il ya des conférences qui
se sont dix ans passés un peu d'entre
eux dans toute la france et donc tous
les cardiologues disons sont preneurs de
cette initiative bon comme toute grosse
machine c'est un peu dur à mettre en
place mais on a pleins d'espoir que ce
plan coeur arriva à voir le jour très
rapidement prévenir avant tout c'est le
but de cette semaine de sensibilisation
en plus des dons qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure on y reviendra d'ailleurs
prévenir avec ce slogan qui est formulée
par les cardiologues 0 cigarette 5
fruits et légumes et 30 minutes
d'activité physique par jour c'est
indispensable pour éviter tout incident
tout accident bien sûr c'est un bon jeu
je pense que tout le monde enfin disons
on est tous pareil quand tout va bien
tout va bien je pense que la prévention
c'est également aussi aller voir son
médecin ceux ci lit à doute aller voir
son cardiologue surtout quand on quand
on a quand on commence à étages et vers
60 65 ans ne pas ce n'est pas à négliger
faire attention comme vous l'avez dit
à l'alimentation
mener une vie saine pas boire trop
d'alcool et et surtout disons faire de
la marche et avoir des activités et
essayer surtout dans un doute consultez
consulter son big c en premier lieu et
donc avec cette semaine de
sensibilisation il ya cette opération
donne au coeur pour donner des fonds
pour ces associations qui y combattent
qui organise la prévention également on
va regarder l'un des clips réalisés à
cette occasion pour donocoeur
et
les maladies cardiovasculaires
c'est partout tout le temps chaque don
d'une solution ne pas banaliser ces
maladies du coeur c'est le mot d'ordre
un petit peu cette année justement pour
ne pas sous-estimer leur impact et puis
on peut les prévenir reprenons prenant
soin au quotidien le rappelait 0
cigarette 5 fruits et légumes 30 minutes
d'activité physique par jour ça semble
aller de soi mais c'est toujours bien de
de le redire on parle également des dons
tout à l'heure j'aimerais qu'on parle
concrètement des actions que vous pouvez
mener avec les associations par exemple
au comité ile de france de l'association
nationale des cardiaques congénitaux
dont vous êtes la présidente quelles
sont les actions concrètes que vous
mettez en place écoutez c'est quand même
un petit peu différent parce que l'on
l'association des cardiaques congénitaux
ce sont des enfants qui sont nés avec
une malformation cardiaque qui
maintenant grandissent ce qui n'était
pas le cas il ya quelques années est
effectivement eu maintenant sont bien
sensibilisés sur sur le fait qu'il faut
se faire suivre par un cardiologue
disons
kiki et qui suit les cas les
cardiopathies congénitales et non pas
les voir on n'a pas n'importe quelle
carte de log tout en sachant que les
cardiologues seront tous compétents mais
un coeur un choeur malformés restera
malgré qu'il soit guéri toujours
accueille un choeur mal formés et puis
les alliances du coeur aussi alors vous
êtes membre du conseil d'administration
où vous êtes présente dans ses
différents différentes associations
organismes aliance du coeur par exemple
intervient comment alors l'alliance du
coeur c'est une fédération qui regroupe
15 associations qui a été créée en 1993
et qui regroupe dix mille adhérents dans
toute la france et qui a aussi cette
mission des taux près de trop près des
des personnes de faire de la prévention
donc c'est ce qu'ont fait disons chaque
année nous organisons des assises du
coeur dans différentes villes nous
avions sur saint quentin en yvelines en
2002 fait aussi une des assises du coeur
et nous espérons peut être renouvelé
cette initiative qui était disons très
très porteuse et qui disent on permet de
se sensibiliser surtout tous et tous ses
effets de de la maladie du coeur et puis
il ya ces brochures aussi un qu'on peut
retrouver sur internet on est tel que
une avec moi ma vie au quotidien avec
une maladie cardiovasculaire à vivre
avec du cholestérol également ses
brochures s'adresse véritablement acquis
et qu'est ce qu'on apprend à l'intérieur
alors ces brochures ont été faites avec
le led d'un laboratoire et il fait par
nous même l'alliance du coeur pour
éditer une brochure nous avons mis un an
de 1 an de travail et ses brochures ont
un petit avantage par rapport aux autres
brochures elles sont elles seules sont
fait disons avec des petites astuces
pour effectivement bien manger et des
petits
dés comment dirais-je la vie quotidienne
la vie affective et sociale avec une
maladie cardiovasculaire c'est le thème
de cette brochure là par exemple c'est
vivre au quotidien avec ça disons que si
vous voulez quand un membre de votre
famille disons un problème cardiaque
tout change et il faut continuer à vivre
on peut avoir malheureusement un
problème cardiaque très très jeune et la
vie ne s'arrête pas il ya les enfants il
ya la famille et on continue à vivre
avec des précautions qui s'intéressent à
vue cette situation qui est
véritablement handicap ainsi l'interview
vasculaire ce que ça peut entraîner en
parler de prévenir on parlait d'
accompagner également une fois les
maladies cardiovasculaires décelée mais
connaissez-vous les gestes qui sauvent
justement en cas de difficultés
cardiaques d'une personne savez vous
comment réagir vos réponses
non pas du tout je n'ai pas mon diplôme
de
secourisme n'auront vraiment non moi si
si c'est si ça m'arrive c'est
directement j'appelle le 18
moi même je vais pas je n'ai jamais fait
ça pour ça oui je le connais mais oui je
les connais oui moi j'ai appris mais
faudrait
les refaire un petit peu pour être plus
sur quoi oui j'ai fait j'ai fait la
formation avec le travail mais vous chat
boucher puis les pulsations cardiaques
j'ai un brevet de secourisme dans la
position latérale de sécurité
et bouche-à-bouche certainement pu
appeler les secours non je connais pas
les gestes qui sauvent ma famille parce
qu elle est institutrice donc elle a dû
faire le secourisme pour le faire mais
moi il faut que je le fasse
il faut que je le fasse tout le monde
dit ça tout le monde ne les connais pas
ces gestes qui sauvent ça aussi ça fait
partie de vos missions zia sur wii tout
à fait si vous voulez quand nous faisons
des démonstrations effectivement on
prend on fait appel à la croix rouge à
des médecins qui nous expliquent qu'ils
expliquent au public bon maintenant il
ya quand même des défibrillateurs
pratiquement dans toute
analyse et donc effectivement comme
disait le monsieur je pense que le mieux
c'est tout de suite d' appeler le 15 ou
le 18 quoi ne pas ne pas attendre des
convois quelqu'un qui est en situation
dramatique il faut mieux appeler pour
rien que de qu'il soit trop tard et puis
à ces formations qui existent bien sûr
de secourisme pour connaître ses
premiers gestes qui sauvent pour
conclure juste un mot sur les 50 ans de
votre association ce sera en 2013
l'année prochaine vous allez fêter les
50 ans de l'association nationale des
cardiaques congénitaux 50 ans d'action
on vous aurez l'occasion de revenir sur
le plateau mais 50 ans d'action vous
êtes satisfaite de ce qui a été fait
durant un demi-siècle très très
satisfaite sachant que disons les
personnes qui ont fondé cette
association étaient tous les deux des
personnes atteintes de cardiopathie
congénitale qui malheureusement sont
décédés mais nous avons fait un long
chemin en sachant que maintenant les
enfants cardiaques sont opéré très
rapidement vivent de plus en plus âgées
malheureusement il ya encore des
cardiopathies qui ne ce qui ne sont pas
opérables donc nous pensons que nous
espérons que ces 50 ans vont être une
chose enfin une manifestation très très
très importantes nous pensons faire face
à la mairie de paris donc nous attendons
un petit peu un tout les retours de
demandes que nous avons fait les 40 ans
étaient faits au sénat était parrainée
par nicolas à bout disons il ya dix
maires de consommateurs également merci
annie bordeaux d'être venu sur ce
plateau le message à retenir en tout cas
c'est de ne pas banaliser et puis
d'aider ces associations il ya le
donocoeur que vous pouvez retrouver sur
internet c'est jusqu'au 4 novembre pour
faire des dons en ligne merci annie
bordeaux toujours sur cette thématique
de la santé le pallium qui intervient
pour la promotion des soins palliatifs à
domicile pour l'aide en fin de vie
organise samedi et dimanche aux essarts
le roi une exposition pour récolter des
fonds peintures sculptures seront en
vente renseignements auprès de
l'association installée dans les locaux
de l'institut de promotion de la santé
cet attrape dans un instant la chronique
culture du mercredi avec johanna soudry
au cours de cette édition je recevrai
aussi l'association terre solidaire pour
une opération de solidarité avec la
zambie et des représentants du musée de
la ville de saint quentin en yvelines
également de la bergerie nationale de
rambouillet pour évoquer les activités
pour vos enfants pour la semaine
prochaine est les vacances se
poursuivent pour le moment montigny le
bretonneux va-t-elle devenir la cité de
l'espace le cnes l'agencé spatiale
française vient d'organiser un congrès
international et l'estaca une école
spécialisée projette de s'y installer le
point avec katherine hull attend
une belle photo de famille dans la salle
du conseil municipal de montigny le
bretonneux réunis autour d'une même
table des spationautes ou encore julie
robinson responsable à la nasa en tout
cette agence spatiale internationale
conviée par le cnes pour réfléchir à
l'interaction entre travaux dans
l'espace et recherche médicale une
rencontre au sommet qui n'est pas dû au
hasard il y a quelques mois le radio
club de montigny avait organisé une
liaison entre le lycée descartes et la
station spatiale internationale
depuis cela a donné des idées à l'agencé
spatiale française on est très favorable
au développement de l'activité spatiale
dans de nombreuses communes en france et
montigny le bretonneux sens parfaitement
dimensionné pour accroître ses activités
dans le domaine spatial il ya un très
bon lycée il ya un radio club amateur
qui est qu'il est très motivé et puis
comme on l'a dit une école d'ingénieur
dans le domaine aérospatial une fac de
médecine qui veut également se
développer dans cette direction bref le
terrain est extrêmement favorable pour
que le cnes et montigny le bretonneux
développe ses activités spatiales ici
l'école d'ingénieurs dont parle françois
spiero sélestat qu'à l'école forme de
futurs ingénieurs chargés d'inventer les
transports de demain transports
terrestres comme spatiaux l'école vient
de signer un accord de partenariat avec
l'entreprise safran à elancourt elles
forment 1500 étudiants par an et va
s'implanter en 2015 à montigny tout
logiquement ce qui nous a intéressés
c'est à la fois tout le tissu industriel
dans le domaine des transports il ya
beaucoup de nos partenaires habituels
que ce soit dans le domaine automobile
ou dans le domaine aéronautique qui sont
aux alentours
montigny de saint quentin en yvelines et
plus largement les yvelines des
partenaires académiques aussi ça fait
longtemps qu'on travaille avec
l'université de versailles
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
montigny le bretonneux cité de l'espace
mais oui pourquoi pas en tout cas le
snec ce ne compte pas s'arrêter en si
bonne voie